la proclamation officielle des résultats
des législatives algériennes
n'interviendra pas de suite en revanche
le taux de participation est connu c'est
le plus faible depuis 20 ans et ce n'est
pas une surprise puisque le scrutin
avait été boycotté par les partisans du
rac la journée de vote qui n'a pas connu
une forte incident a tout de même été
troublé en kabylie six bassins vacher
but envoyés sur place en algérie nous en
dit plus des élections législatives
anticipées largement boudée par les
algériens
un taux de participation de 30,20 %
c'est loin de l'objectif du gouvernement
qui tablait sur une participation à au
moins 50%
à titre de comparaison il se situait aux
dernières législatives de 2010 est à
35,70 pour 107 en kabylie au nord du
pays que la participation a été quasi
nul avec 0 79% à béjaïa et 0 62% à tizi
ouzou les deux grandes villes de cette
région selon des chiffres officiels
préliminaires dans cette région du nord
de l'algérie le scrutin d'hier a été
marquée par des protestations et des
saccages d'urnes selon la ligue
algérienne des droits de l'homme de
nombreux bureaux de vote ont dû fermer
leurs portes bien avant 20h 136 centres
de vote et 229 bureau exactement un
scrutin apportées par les pro
gouvernement est largement boudés par le
irak et une partie de l'opposition qui
dénonce une mascarade électorale et
réclame toujours un changement radical
du système de gouvernance 407 députés
issus de plus de 1500 listes pour cette
nouvelle composition de l'assemblée
populaire nationale
les résultats attendus normalement
aujourd'hui pourrait être finalement
annoncé deux mains par l'autorité
nationale et indépendante des élections